it's a hot
dry day in july when you decide to
explore the amazon basin by boat
[Music]
you feel pretty comfortable with your
local guide showing you the exotic
environment
but all of a sudden your boat capsizes
and you fall overboard into the still
warm water
luckily you're a strong swimmer wait a
minute
what are all those fishes and why are
they swarming
this is how to survive a piranha feeding
frenzy
there are 40 to 60 species of piranhas
the majority are timid by nature and
scavenge meat from other fish and
carcasses they find in the water
however the red bellied piranha is the
most vicious
and aggressive it's also the most common
and it looks like it's the species you
now find yourself swimming among
since it's the dry season the water is
low and this shoal has grown to over 100
fish
with razor sharp teeth set in powerful
clamping jaws
and they're hungry you can't help but
think of that news report from january
2020 when more than 30 people were
attacked by piranhas in the aptly named
parana brazil this surge happened over
several days
and prompted local authorities to post
strict warning signs
how do piranhas locate prey what parts
of the body do they attack first
how can deep water save you
step one be as still as possible
piranhas are stealthy opportunists and
are attracted to sick
dying animals if you panic and begin to
thrash around
this will tell predators you're in
trouble and they will begin to swarm
make your movements slow and deliberate
step two don't make noise
red-bellied piranhas locate their prey
with excellent hearing
combined with teamwork
the shoal fans out in search of prey
once they find a tasty morsel
they communicate acoustically to each
other which signals the feast to begin
so it's important you make as little
noise as possible
don't yell or scream and tread carefully
step 3 swim to deeper water
attacks on humans have been on the rise
over the last decade
scientists believe it's caused by an
increase in dams on the amazon river
which slows the current and attracts
swimmers
this slow-moving warm prime swimming
water
is exactly what piranhas love
if you can quietly move toward deeper
water
where it's colder and the current is
quicker currents can be dangerous
themselves if you're not a strong
swimmer
but they will help safeguard you from an
unwelcome feeding frenzy
[Applause]
step four protect your hands and feet
exposed hands and feet are vulnerable
main targets
so protecting these areas before you
potentially go out in piranha infested
waters
will help you survive nasty bites they
will still hurt
but maybe you'll be missing less chunks
when you finally escape
think thick leather gloves and solid
shoes
[Music]
it was united states president theodore
roosevelt who turned piranha
into a popular super villain in a book
chronicling his jungle journey
through the brazilian wilderness he
witnessed an entire
cow being devoured down to the bone
but experts believe this shocking event
was staged for the president's benefit
sorry teddy in truth these beasts aren't
quite
that monstrous after all like most
animals
piranhas are more scared of you than you
are of them
giving them a wide berth is your best
bet especially if they're guarding a
clutch of eggs
or are especially ravenous honestly
you may have bigger things to be worried
about if you fall into a river in the
amazon you can learn all about
caimans deadly parasites and more in
other
how to survive episodes
[Music]
you